voici biaka n'a qu'à moi et les nommés
de la chanson francophone de l'année
avec la même maître gims evianais djadja
pas à vannes hatamura bon ben là pas
choisi un nom simple non plus aya
nakamura est ce soir notre invité alors
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas une personne n'y
a pas un animateur qui a comme mais
aussi à prononcer son nom correctement
aya nakamura
c'est ça pour vous les moments
difficilement map les bouchoux strates
août tout comme un enfant je dors mal
moi et ma soeur s'appelle calystène
francesca omd caligula et bouchra vous
appeler comme ça on n'a jamais s'est
jamais plainte et si c'était une vanne
non a dit que c'était van cleef d'envoi
on pense à caligula
[Rires]
vous fait peur c'est vous qui
s'offraient par exemple et sincèrement
là elle exagère elle a une émission mais
vraiment été retenue
ils étaient tous aux petits soins pour
elle les questions alors c'est clair que
c'est pas son public c'est pas les
chroniqueurs tout ça il ne pense pas
qu'ils aient kutahya nakamura
mais ouais alors que les oreillons new
york times je pense qu'elle a peut-être
un petit peu pris la grosse tête je vais
bien sûr vous êtes une jeune femme noire
et vous le dit la france n'est pas
habitué à voir une fille à la peau noire
chanter et réussir vraiment aia on en
est encore là mais je dis pas que la
france est assistant loin de là du tout
mais qui a vu son nom mais après c'est
vrai que la france n'est pas habitué à
voir un artiste
oui moi en fait renoir encore voilà de
notoriété de succès on n'a pas marché le
mois très vite je me suis rendu compte
que
c'était pas habituelles en général quand
j'étais petit j'ai pas eu de modèle noir
enfin je peux pas citer une artiste noir
en fait quand j'étais chez vous
n'arriviez pas vous identifier dans nos
noms mais alors alex est bon depuis ma
naissance a dit gilles moi je moi aussi
j'ai re visionner cette émission 20
minutes elle a été reçue comme une reine
vous avez vraiment bossé et leur dossier
il y avait des magnétos ils ont mis en
valeur tout le temps je suis désolé
c'est madame gerald donc j'existe et
hayart une carrière ça se fait sur le
talent mais ça fait aussi sur les
rapports humains
donc attention parce que quand elle sera
un petit peu en dessous personne ne lui
tendra la main je attention il ya la
camorra c'est daniel moreau qu'elle
insiste pour lui faire dire y'a une
différence parce qu'on est noir ou pas
il ya différents voit que c'est
insistant je comprends moi son malaise
et je trouve que c'est bien d'avoir
aujourd'hui des filles qui ont du
caractère qui se laisse pas faire s'il
remplit des salles il ya des milliers de
gens qui la suivent
elle sort elle en a rien à [ __ ] qu'on
les aime quand même pas très clairement
mais sam ans elle veut qu'on la respecte
et à la raison elle était respectée
ce raid a visé était une façon de
l'accueillir avec la première question
qui est alors voilà vous dit à la fin
c'était fait bugger la première c'est
pas un hasard si à chaque fois on
prononce mal son nom si à chaque fois
nous voilà des stades
et entièrement d'accord avec magali que
j'irai voir le 9 décembre à bagua nord
il ya un système il ya un système
médiatique qui consiste à la casse et et
c'est d'ailleurs là c'est parce que ça
vient nakamura crier au complot c'est
vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'elle passe dans
la division il ya un petit un petit quad
ya des débats un petit dérapage
souvenez-vous de deux bagues avait dit
nikos à la fin de l'interview merci
d'avoir été avec no mercy a tout à
l'heure à vous restait maintenant à
faire ne s'est pas terminée c'est pas
terminé c'est pas terminé mais ces
théories complotistes faut arrêter quoi
qu'à mon retour on de la dore elle vend
plein de disques il faut arrêter elle
s'en fout
qu'on vienne enfin je vois pas ce que ça
change dont l'école est sa façon c'est
bon fois dans la série savent qu'elle va
répondre ici savent que c'est une fille
qui ne se laisse pas faire et nivelles
du buzz et ils ont trouvé le truc ça
fait du bien ça fait parler il la
chauffe
elles savent qu'elle va répondre et donc
forcément ça fait parler du point de
croix que nikos effet l'arrêt pour
corinne et du belge en action
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont avec les accents ou
je ne sais pas jb non mais dans ces cas
là aussi c'est raciste dans ces cas là
si on leur supprime et tu veux du peuple
a remporté ce quils et j'en prend
l'accent marseillais ce que ça vous
énerve ça vous agace
est ce que vous êtes blessé dans votre
orgueil ni non c'est pour ça que je
comprends pas si on fait des accents
aussi à l'époque ont des accents pour
qu'on peut pas rire à la faute des
accents des différences oui qu'on ne
compte pas revenir pour ovi raya
nakamura je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que cette fille elle est vraiment
quelque chose de la star quoi qu'il en
soit je sais que ça agace beaucoup de
gens cette fille à la 4g très fort là
quelque chose de la star par les 900 kg
de l'auto dérision pour qu'à la bande
annonce
garmin humain que le pied elle peut pas
jouer au foot et bien on fait plein de
choses on peut rire de faire ce que je
te battre de quoi que je te battrais
offrir aux éleveurs jade c'est pas
divisible il est marseillais
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi
voilà on y est allés là c'était une
blague
ces faits contredit gens à je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas nouveauté il apprend
la peinture des mois j'ai posé deux
marseillais je suis marié à marseille
avec gaudin en amont marcel boiteux
poète alors voilà donc c'est bon pot sur
diana pour vous bon vous n'êtes pas
d'accord visiblement mais quand même
c'est vrai grade et on lui pose des
questions sur ses chansons avoue qu'elle
explique les téléskis cachant des images
de cette les questions qu'on lui pose
cette fois c'est que ça serait bien
c'est quoi le cookie qui fait là tout
cas une balle sert n'apporte la
confidence à la poupée dans le
feuilleton les side c'est le groupe avec
qui je
je bosse vivez une balance dans le
groupe l'a sauvée regarde non avaient
tous les mecs sur le bas côté
on comprend aussi accablé l'a fait des
choses que vous avez inventé
non non non ça c'est de jouer cab les
goûts ouais bah oui ça se dit beaucoup
chez les jeunes savaient que ce débat
devait mieux mais écoutez vous et la
même question pour expliquer amende et à
brûler les paroles de sa chanson sa
tombe et d'autres choses il y place des
lices dans une émission dont c est le
public n'est pas forcément habitué à ce
que haskell à ses paroles je suis désolé
moi j'ai appris des choses tout qui je
ne savais pas aller au marché
bernard c'est vrai que elle a ce côté
staal espace pour que tu espères dans le
grand est les deux mois parce qu'elle
les a